one of the questions i get asked all the
time is how do you find good property
investment deals
on rightmove see rightmover's got
literally
hundreds of thousands of property
investment opportunities for sale for
rent so how do you even go about it i
mean i live in buckinghamshire i'm
typing beckonsfield booking i'm sure and
people might say oh the area is so
expensive i mean if you if you look at
buckinghamshire you know the types of
houses that you know this one's 4.6
million pounds beautiful house um
four and a half million that they're
quite expensive houses so
you know i wouldn't necessarily say just
you beckonsfield only let's say we're
going to do 20 miles
radius of our house
we've already got here
29 000 search results
and you can see
there's some absolute mansions so what i
want to show you on this video is i'm
going to show you how regardless of the
area regardless of the strategy that
you're wanting to do
how you can find good opportunities
one and a half thousand pound piece of
land
right down would you get planning for
that um very unlikely how do i know
because there's nothing really around
it's quite isolated
if there was like houses here
then you might be thinking okay mate
it's probably also flood risk is that
that looks like water to me um
anyway we're not gonna get too
distracted we're going to look for
property investments good deals if
you're looking for hmos if you're
looking for buy to let's if you're
looking for buy refurbished refinance or
flips how do you find good opportunities
so
i'm going to do this from scratch i
haven't actually
prepared for this because i didn't want
to just be like hey here's a deal that i
found earlier i wanted you to really see
the actual process of doing this so i
mean look there's properties on auction
this is a block of apartments it could
work it could be good it's no way gonna
sell for ten thousand pounds it's gonna
probably sell for more like i don't know
how much maybe um three four five
hundred thousand um
or more don't be mixed up with the guide
price and the actual um reserve price
and purchase price so what am i going to
do well the first thing is let's look
for houses
um i prefer houses to flats unless i own
the whole block because if it's a flat
it's a leasehold
all flats in england
are leasehold which means that you don't
actually own the land you just own the
flat which means you're gonna have to
pay a service charge ground rent you
don't actually own the land
so i prefer houses so
be mindful of stuff like this shared
ownership because shared ownership means
that you're going to buy it and you're
only going to own part of it 50
but then you're also going to have to
pay rent on the other 50 that you don't
own they're very difficult to sell
afterwards see these are auction
properties auction properties are
um
again they're good but just be mindful
that when you bid you have to actually
buy it so the laws are all very
different so look you can see there's a
lot of different properties how on earth
do you weigh up which ones are good
which ones are bad let's stay away from
auctions today because auction
properties are it's a slightly different
um beast so let's stay away from auction
properties i'm i'm going to be searching
now around beckonsfield buckinghamshire
you're not going to buy a buy to let i'm
not going to just buy a house and rent
it out traditionally because the return
on investment is going to be terrible
the only way i'm going to do a um
a deal around here is if i can add value
so this one looks interesting i could
potentially get a side extension here
and build above the garage which could
work very nicely um let's see the
condition of it looks pretty decent if
you're buying a property to flip it
really really is nice to buy properties
that are
in bad condition because if they're in
bad condition that means that no one
else is able to buy it on a mortgage
which means it's cash only which
which limits a lot of a lot of buyers
okay so this one's 250 let's see if it's
in bad condition i want to find
something really nasty really run down
if it's really run down it's really
nasty that's a good thing because it
means there's profit to be made if it's
already in good condition like there we
go this one just reduced today bang
reduced today
no chain
it's on the market for 250 or offers in
excess of and it's just dropped in price
it is in luton
which is just down the road from me
maybe i don't know maybe 30 40 minutes
the house as you can see
needs a full refurb so what i'm looking
at is i'm looking at what the end value
is going to be okay so if this property
um is
hampton road is on for 250
can look at it it could be that you
could potentially turn it into a hmo
bang
that would be nice
how would you do that well
you'd rent this room out this room out
potentially this room out there's no
measurement so we need to see the sizes
and then you'd put a corridor here and
you would turn this into a bedroom by
putting a partition wall which would be
which would which would be absolutely
beautiful and then this would become
communal space all around here
could add a lot of value to the property
potentially could do it as a hmo
um
i'd need to look into the rules in luton
well let's do that now
for a start is article 4 in luton
article 4 direction looks like it is
which means that you can't turn a
house
into a hmo
without getting planning permission um
is it in the whole of luton i'm not sure
there should be a map somewhere i don't
want to get too sidetracked because we
don't even know if this house is going
to be any good or not so what's the
first thing that i'm going to do well
what i want to see is this is just being
reduced motivated seller it's on my
purple bricks which means i can i can
view it and meet the actual owner direct
which is really cool
um what are the ha what's the house next
door selling for that's what i want to
know what other houses in the street
selling for how big is it
it doesn't say the measurements of the
property at all
if i want to know what the end value is
i really need to know the size of the
house so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to find the size of the house by
firstly finding the address now as you
can see the address is not on right move
it never is
so if you want to know the address um
what you can do is well for a start you
can just zoom in
boom 94
i know the address
94 hampton road
let's find the postcode
94 hampton road lu4 8ar so if i want to
find the size of this property i'm going
to have to go to the epc register
and we're going to be able to find not
only the energy performance certificate
which will show us how energy efficient
this property is and whether it's legal
to actually rent it out but also we'll
find the exact size of the house which
means that we can start finding out what
the end value is
so the um
number 94
so the house it's epcd which is fine
right now but in 2025 that's gonna it's
gonna have to be a c um it's 75 square
meters bang
so the house is 75 square meters
it's on for 250 and it's in hampton road
so what i'm going to now do i can see
although it's in bad condition i know
that this property actually doesn't need
much work
i mean it really just needs
very light cosmetic work carpets and
paint would probably be enough to really
lift this property the carpets are
disgusting the walls don't look that bad
let's see if i can see the roof
um i can't see the roof the roof can be
something that can be quite expensive so
let's see if we can find the roof by
looking on street view
um
well we we
we could do that
number 94.
see i can see that this roof here needs
changing
but
you can tell whether a roofing is
changing by looking at it
see this roof looks okay this roof
look at it the tiles are all falling off
and that needs a new roof so let's see
if we can and a new roof will typically
cost a roundabout on a house this size
probably about eight thousand pounds so
that's 54 we know ours is number 94
so we're going up the road this way
so 94 let's see if we can look at the
roof because this is going to add a lot
of money onto a refurb also the
electrics will add a lot onto the refurb
um the boiler these are the things we
need to look at okay here we go number
94 this is the house so the structure
looks okay
a little bit of fixing up here to do but
i can't see any major cracks or anything
the roof looks okay
good
it doesn't look too bad
it doesn't look per it doesn't look
perfect and obviously you need to get
over um you know
a survey on the house but i can't see
any red flags of anything devastating to
the house apart from carpets paint and
and and cosmetic things so if we were to
buy that house for 250 what would it be
worth if we then spent let's say we
spent 15 20 grand making it beautiful
what would it then be worth because
there's no point buying it for 250
spending 15 grand on it but then the end
value is only 265 because we've made no
money so let's have a look at
um
property sell history
okay so there's nothing so the house
hasn't been bought or sold for a long
time so that's interesting to note
and looking at the uh what's for sale in
the street so this one's on for 220
280 300 310 300 so
and none of these are in particularly
good condition to be perfectly honest uh
like this one is
also in reasonably poor condition
so the houses are kind of ranging really
from from from 220 but this one's in
also really poor condition
nice see i'm thinking this one might
actually be a better brr
this property is in terrible condition
it wouldn't get a mortgage if you tried
to get a mortgage on this property you'd
be declined it's on for 220 let's see
how big it is
so again let's see if we can find the
address
really nice this looks like it's got a
lot of value to be added
really really really like it
let's see oh there's no floor plan it's
got three bedrooms and two reception
rooms
interesting so um if we look at the
property sale history
220 market information
so that was the other one that we looked
at so i think this one's probably going
to be potentially a better a better
opportunity
now rather than just looking at what has
what's for sale we also need to look at
three bedroom properties that have
actually sold
in the area so if this was in good
condition we can see it's three bedrooms
uh can't see the address of the property
so i'd need to call the agent and find
the address and get the exact
measurements but it looks considerably
bigger than the um than this property
which is on at 300 000 which is also not
in great condition either but nowhere
near as bad let's see what's sold
okay
so
i'm seeing a lot of cheap properties
that have sold this is really
interesting it shows that even in
today's market which is booming
properties that are for sale
[Music]
are still getting massively reduced
because the ones that have sold you can
see there's a lot of negotiations going
on so i'm not i'm not sure about this
property it's interesting i'd have to
bring the agent to
to to get the address um it's very
difficult to see so i'm going to move on
from this area now because as i said you
can do literally this this this strategy
that i'm doing is applicable anywhere
anyhow uh if i want to go up let's say
into the midlands or if i want to go up
north
if you go up north buy to let is a
little bit better let's go to
uh luton to leeds
not london
leeds
houses for sale and again i'm going to
do within 40 miles because i actually
care where it is at all i'm looking for
houses
and let's see what we've got
now one of the things that i like to do
up north is because houses are so cheap
the yields are better see for instance a
house up north let's search for minimum
i want to miss the auction so i don't
want to go too cheap but let's let's do
let's do 50 grand
okay now these houses up north for like
50 grand
uh like this house for instance added
yesterday two bed house oh it's a shared
ownership forget that
guide price
okay here we go this is uh 67 667 square
feet two bedroom house this house that's
on for 50 grand
is is like a tenth of the price of
houses that are let's say in and around
london or even luton it's a tenth of the
price but the rent will not be a tenth
the rent of this house might be four or
five hundred quid a month whereas the
rent of a house ten times the value but
namely a five hundred thousand pound
house isn't going to be
like five grand a month so the yield is
much better up north so this property
again we can see the address is 26
26 elmwood street
um
what rent would we get for this well if
you want to work out the rent that you'd
get and let's say we're doing this as a
straightforward buy to let so we're
gonna get the postcode so we know it's
26 elmwood street burnley
so if we type 26
elmo street burnley
we can see the full postcode is bb11 4bp
now this time we're going to go to
rightmove and we're going to search
houses for rent
and we'll type the postcode and we're
going to be looking just within a
quarter of a mile and we're going to
include let agreed properties
um
a quarter of a mile include let agreed
and see what we can get all right cool
so there's a there's a there's a mixture
of properties
um
let agreed 550 450
368 but i think that might be
yeah that's a house share so it's just
for one room
interesting
so the rooms are rented out for three
six eight
but they're nice but the rooms are
rented out for four six eight oh e m
solutions i know them tina is the owner
of that of that agency that's another
thing you really want to be connected to
the to the agents so
the rooms are renting out for 368
but the entire property is renting out
for
between 450 and 550. interesting what do
you think's more lucrative renting out
the rooms or written out the whole house
well obviously it's more lucrative to
rent out the rooms so if i go back now
for houses for sale
so
let's look specifically now in this area
let's hone this down
so if i do within say half a mile
i'm looking between 50 and 80 grand
i'm looking for two bed houses upwards
i'm not going to include sold ones
because there's no point
and i'll search from lowest
okay let's see what we got
so
obviously we've got this one which is
cool
um two bedrooms i'm also i really wanna
if i'm looking for a two bed i really
wanna find one with with two reception
rooms as well so i can i can try and if
possible if you're doing a hmo you
really wanna get four
rooms um going so okay this one's a two
bed
this one's a four bed oh my goodness
four bed
let's have a little look see let's look
at the floor plans now the rooms if
you're doing it as a hmo
need to be a minimum of 70 square foot
condition looks okay
there's no floor plan four rooms okay
this is going on auction oh it looks
like it did go on auction already
it's a it's already a hmo
so it's a four bed hmas already gone to
auction and missed i mean now we're
almost in what in
april time
so the fact that this is still on the
market
looks like maybe it didn't sell
and we're talking 68 grand
and we know the rooms are gonna rent out
for about three six eight each
what what's that in total like one
thousand four hundred one thousand five
hundred
um this one's got two reception rooms
there's no floor plan but it's got two
bedrooms and it's got two reception
rooms
sold of 10 in situ probably don't want
that see the rent on that's probably
about 550 i would imagine so the roi is
going to be decent
and and the real key is as well with
these properties is to
actually book viewings see that could be
a bedroom easy peasy
got a bathroom upstairs let's see how
big this bedroom is
okay
so 11 by 10
okay cool so these
rooms
are huge because these rooms are 100
square feet or more
okay you can see they're all over 100
square feet that means that you wouldn't
need a communal room
because if the rooms are 100 square feet
or more you don't need a communal room
so what you could do is you could put a
corridor in here and then that is going
to be a large double bedroom over 100
square feet
that's a large double bedroom over 100
square feet so is that so that bang
you've got four rooms you could
potentially even put in like an ensuite
into one of the rooms or even two of the
rooms if there's if there's space
because these rooms are huge
it's on the market at 75 grand
the rooms are massive look the second
bedroom the smallest room is 15.2 by 11
13. fourteen by eleven
and then you've got
fifteen by thirteen huge eleven by ten
plenty big enough reception room one and
reception room one you're not having to
do anything because there's already a
partition so you're gonna put a
partition here you've got four double
rooms
even that room is way over the is way
over the 100 square foot let's see where
this is
not too far from a train station
like it's near stuff there's burnley's
uh center
you've got the cinema
shops
school
hotel
things around starbucks lots of things
popping
you've got a university here as well i
think i just saw that i just see
i don't know burnley at all i just
literally just found this property now i
don't know but i can see there's a lot
of stuff in the area so if we go now to
use spare room
dot co uk see this is just how i find
deals
i know this property is right in burnley
center
let's look for
people looking for rooms in burnley oh
my goodness there's someone just posted
an advert today 75 pounds a week which
is a 303 pounds a month 450 300 550 so
there's people looking to pay let's see
what rooms are available like sort of
350 400
these rooms are in burnley
you're talking about 350 400 a month so
if you could rent these rooms for just
350 each where's the property now
um i've lost it that's it gone forever
no here it is if you could rent these
rooms
for 350 each that's going to be a total
rent of 1400 pound a month
now on average of hmos half of the rent
is going to go towards expenses you'll
probably be left with about 700 pounds a
month profit
but the house is only 75 grand
i mean
this is crazy the return on investment
is awesome so i'll be booking a viewing
on that i'll be speaking to hm
management companies
i'd be going around
maybe your areas booking the houses on
things that you could potentially push
the value upon there's just the thing is
this with rightmove there's hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of properties
available you just need to know how to
spot a good opportunity and see a see a
property that's not going to have any
value to be added and when you know to
do that rightmove just becomes your
absolute best friend
[Music]